Hello Freak bitches,
boom.
And we're live.
Let's have a toast to Hugh Hefner.
Yes.
We lost one of the Great Dick slingers of the 20th century.
Certainly did in last time.
He literally had a place where guys could go to be leches.
Yeah,
you could just go and you had a mansion where everybody knew there was going to
be a bunch of hose.
That's why they went.
Yeah,
they,
they went there on purpose and there was guys that like were notorious for
hanging around the mansion for going to all imagine parties.
Did you ever go?
I went twice.
I went once for a marijuana policy project,
um,
thing.
I think that was a company that was putting it together.
A or a hosted something and there's bands and stuff like that was kind of
interesting.
That's fun.
And then the other time I went was for fear factor.
We did some thing for fear factor with the playboy playmates.
Do you have to meet?
He'll,
I never met a man.
No,
never met him.
And he's just,
I think at,
by that time he's,
he's old and I think he just wants to chill.
Yeah.
He was just kind of done.
I never went there.
I tried to get in,
a girl tried to get me in and I guess they,
they googled me and she goes,
I guess I didn't have enough credits.
Oh,
come on,
sit.
What?
What was,
I couldn't get in.
And she's like,
yeah,
they have to look you up.
And she was nice,
but they said no.
How long ago was this?
Probably two years ago.
Oh my God.
I know.
I didn't qualify to go.
Like,
I didn't qualify to go with his fucking girls and fucking test.
So crazy.
You didn't have enough credits,
I guess,
sell it or maybe they didn't have the right credits or maybe they just didn't
care,
like whatever.
You know what I mean?
I didn't,
I wasn't even that mad,
but I was like,
Eh,
whatever.
Credits.
Oh,
gross.
Yeah.
She said something like that.
But uh,
she was trying to be really nice.
Like she was trying to let me down easy because she felt bad because we were
friends and she wanted to go,
like,
you just don't qualify to come here and look at these tits.
I was just really hurtful.
It was a weird place because it was super outdated.
Like you heard about the grotto,
the grotto,
you go to the grotto and has a phone from like the 1970s there and you're like,
what is this?
They left it like for apply for the vibe.
The old school vibe I guess.
Or they just never updated it because we're like,
you know,
he's sold the place or it was for sale.
But one of the caveats of purchase was that he had to live in the building until
he died.
Yeah.
Yup.
But it was like some preposterous amount of money.
Like $200 million or something crazy.
Well,
the land is really valuable.
So what do they do with that now?
Do they knock it down?
I mean he's there no nostalgia to it.
Is it like kind of died on the vine anyway or do you fucking what he did?
Well,
he has a son and his son probably inherited it.
His son,
I think was running the magazine.
They tried for a to have no nudity.
Oh,
terrible idea.
It's like fucking,
it's like my mechanic fucking thing with no cars in it.
Who wants to just read that shit stupid.
It's like having a New York Times article with all ads.
Like what do you,
where's the fucking intellectual stimulation here?
And you fucking idiots.
That's a really bad,
no,
nudity is a terrible decision.
Well,
they were always in this weird area,
right?
Because [inaudible] was like the only acceptable pornographer like Larry Flynt
who did a lot for free speech,
who did a lot for exposing corrupt politicians,
but they would show vaginas and assholes.
Yeah.
And because of that,
he was always thought as a gross guy.
Yeah.
Well even their social commentary.
I remember when I was a kid,
it was one,
it might,
who is the feminist?
Uh,
Gloria.
oh no,
no.
Gloria Allred on my guide,
and I think it was a Gloria Steinem parody,
but it was like,
you know,
her licking the girl's pussy,
that head period blood.
It was like some fucking vile thing.
He would do the most vile political colic.
He really showed his disdain of those people.
He was great.
He's a crazy guy.
He's still alive.
That fucker.
Yeah.
It's shot,
you know,
and paralyzed like way back in the day,
right?
Yeah.
77 maybe it was that late at night.
I think it was I that were 76.
Yeah.
He's getting,
it's still got a bunch of casinos and stuff.
He's still out there kicking it,
but like,
who the hell is buying hustler?
Um,
well,
it's funny you mentioned I had my manager got one today.
I haven't bought one in many years because there's a,
I did an interview for them and,
uh,
it was actually a really good interview and they quoted me accurately show I'm
in December's hustling,
which is out today.
Wow.
Yeah.